- [Zac] "Halloween III" is
known as the black sheep,
the "Tokyo Drift", the "Zelda II"
of the Halloween franchise.
For that reason, the series connections,
we've now come to expect are more tenuous,
but if we inspect the movie closely,
some of its hidden secrets
start to come into view.
The story follows Dr. Daniel Challis,
who was called into the hospital
to take care of an injured patient
and prescribes a medication
called Thorazine.
- 100 milligrams, Thorazine.
- [Zac] This calls back
to the first "Halloween"
where Dr. Loomis plans
to use the same drug
to sedate Michael Myers.
- What do I give him when we
take him in front of the judge?
- Thorazine.
- Barely be able to sit up.
- That's the idea.
- [Zac] After realizing the
suspicious circumstances
of the patient's death, Challis
decides to go investigate
with the man's daughter, Ellie Grimbridge.
Before leaving town, he rings
his ex-wife at a payphone.
This is the same location
featured in "Halloween II",
where the nurse, Karen, announces
that she never wants to go
to another Halloween party.
- Especially not at Stevie Mathis's house.
- [Zac] The biggest connection
to the original two
Halloween movies, though,
which many viewers are not aware of,
has to do with the reason that
the villain, Conal Cochran,
has put this elaborate plan into motion.
To learn the little known-connection
between him and Michael Myers,
stick around to the end of this video.
(heavy metal music begins)
- [TV commercial] Three
more weeks till Halloween,
Halloween, Halloween.
Three more weeks till
Halloween, Silver Shamrock.
- Welcome to Things You Missed.
Just one year after killing
off the popular slasher,
Michael Myers, series
producers John Carpenter
and Debra Hill were
interested in continuing
with their original idea
of an anthology series.
Where each movie would
tell an unrelated story
taking place on Halloween night.
As always I'll be joined in this video
by the literal prime
minister of Haddonfield,
Jimmy Champane.
- It's commonly thought that
"Halloween III: Season of the Witch"
is the only movie in
the Halloween franchise
that doesn't feature Michael Myers
But that's not exactly true.
We see Michael in a commercial
for a television airing
of the original
"Halloween", which tells us
that "Halloween" is only
a movie in this universe.
- [Zac] Tommy Lee Wallace was excited by
the prospect of getting
to tell a new story.
So after declining to
take over "Halloween II"
he signed down as the director
of the third installment.
That's actually his voice in the
Silver Shamrock commercials.
- [TV announcer] All you lucky kids
with Silver Shamrock masks
gather around your TV set,
put on your masks and watch.
- I learned this while trying to determine
if this was the same
voice as Dr. Dementia,
the horror movie marathon
host in the first two films.
- [TV Host] Lock your
doors, bolt your windows
and turn off the lights.
- They're similar, but
I never did find out
if Dr. Dementia was voiced by Tommy.
- I mean, I haven't heard otherwise.
So let's just go with it.
- [Zac] "Halloween III" is a weird movie,
but the same oddities
that turned off critics
and fans in the early eighties
are part of what makes it a
cult classic decades later.
With that all being said,
let's get into the things you missed.
(knives sharpening)
(dramatic music beginning)
- [Zac] The opening credits are displayed
over a series of lines, appearing close up
on a TV screen.
We don't know it yet,
but what we're seeing
is a very zoomed in version of the video
that triggers the brainwash sequence.
I love how right from the first shot,
you already know this
movie is going to be funny
and just the way that this
guy runs makes me laugh.
An hour later, he arrives at a gas station
where we see the news report
about the missing Stonehenge monument.
- [TV announcer] It
weighs more than five tons
making its disappearance a mystery indeed.
- I'm not exactly sure why Cochran felt
like he needed to steal
the entire giant stone,
because he only ended up
using like a small chunk
of that monument to enact his plan.
Wouldn't it be smarter just
to take the chunk you need
instead of removing an
entire ancient monument?
I get that we find out that all you need
is an extremely small
speck to do major damage
and that's what ends up in every single
Silver Shamrock mask.
But still the amount
they're using in these masks
is absolutely tiny compared
to that massive monument,
which everyone realized was stolen.
- [Zac] So the Stonehenge news
report sets up the big reveal
about what the company's
true intentions are.
But the next program after
this is also significant.
- [Radio announcer] When we
come back Trina will be here
to tell you what you
can do about junk mail.
Stay with us.
- [Zac] Junk mail is a form
of overbearing advertising,
which ties into the main
message of this movie.
The entire crux of Cochran's
plan relies on children
to be brainwashed by the Silver Shamrock
commercials that dominate the airwaves
in the days leading up to Halloween.
Michael Myers may not show up
to chase any teenagers this time,
but Daniel Challis is constantly chased
by this catchy yet annoying
Silver Shamrock jingle.
Almost every location
in the movie has screens
or radios manipulating
children to buy their masks
and wear them on the big
Halloween night giveaway.
There are so many screens,
I started to wonder
if I wasn't at Universal Studios.
That's a stupid joke.
- We are totally joking.
Universal please let us come
to Halloween Horror Nights
this year.
- [Zac] Just as the first
Halloween makes a comment
about the sexual revolution
still ongoing from the 1960's,
"Season of the Witch" taps into concerns
of the effects of television on children.
A discussion that was
still picking up steam
from the late 1970s.
Even though television is
no longer a relevant medium
for young people, the themes
of this movie remain pertinent.
It was not that long ago that YouTube
implemented strict rules regarding content
made for children to make sure
that they aren't subjected
to targeted advertising.
And also a bunch of other lame
restrictions for some reason.
Let's just say it was the only
time, ever, where operating
a horror themed channel actually paid off.
- Yo Zac, let's make a
Cocomelon horror movie.
- Yeah, I'm sure that
won't get us struck down
off YouTube immediately.
(dramatic musical note plays)
We see the effects of over advertising
towards kids on Challis's own offspring.
They each get Silver Shamrock masks
and huddle around the TV
when the commercial comes on.
(Silver Shamrock Jingle playing)
- [TV Announcer] Yes, kids you too,
can own one of the big Halloween three.
That's right, three horrific
masks to choose from.
- The masks are marketed
as the big Halloween three.
Yes, let's go ahead and get our jokes in
about the title of the
movie being in the movie.
And there are many threes or triples
in this movie and I'm not sure how many
of them are intentional.
So I'm just going to show
them and let you decide.
Also of note, the deadly
Silver Shamrock program
at the end is airing on
three different channels.
There are, perhaps, other
number games at play here.
Mr. Grimbridge's room at
the hospital is room 13.
If you've seen my final destination videos
you know all about how
that's the unlucky number,
but, in this case, it's
also the reverse of 31.
As in October 31, Halloween night.
There are also a lot of
instances of the number six.
The motel room that
Challis and Ellie stay in
is room six, the town's curfew
goes into effect at 6:00 PM,
and the activation code for
the commercial is 6, 6, 6.
The number of the devil.
It's not just the numbers that
we should be paying attention
to though.
There are also several names
that have a deeper meaning
than what meets the eye.
- (scary, intense music begins)
- (creepy music begins)
- [Zac] When chalice gets to the hospital,
his new patient is Harry
Grimbridge, a shop owner
who apparently discovered
the Silver Shamrock secret
and was hunted down by
the androids who worked
for Mr. Cochran.
The assassin promptly leaves the hospital
and gets into his Plymouth
Fury and self-destructs.
(car exploding)
- Seeing as John Carpenter
produced this movie
and was absolutely
instrumental in getting it made
this might've been yet another hint
as to what one of his
future projects would be.
That's because his adaptation
of the Stephen King novel,
"Christine", would come
out a few years later.
For those of you who don't
know what that's about,
it's about a kid who buys
a cursed 1958 Plymouth,
and then ends up destroying
it because it has a mind
of its own and starts killing people.
Now the car in "Halloween
III", isn't an exact match,
but it's the same make and model
so I feel like it's worth
bringing up nonetheless.
Before you light us up
down in the comments,
I know that John Carpenter
has said multiple times
over the years, that this
is his least favorite movie
that he's ever made.
But I've also seen
recently that he started
to come around on it.
So yeah, I absolutely love it.
And I watch it all the time.
I'm glad he's starting in like it too.
- Is there also a second
Stephen King connection
in "Season of the witch"?
Probably not, but I'm going
to mention it anyways.
Inside Mr. Grimbridge's store
there are these Jack in
the Box clowns in a box
that says boats.
Director Tommy Lee Wallace
would go on to direct
a production where a creepy
clown steals a young boys boat.
"It" would not come out
for another eight years,
however.
So I'm just going to chalk this one up
to just being a fun coincidence.
Perhaps a more intentional
detail can be seen
when Ellie is brought in to ID her father
after his death.
The county Sheriff's name
badge reads Dunsmuir.
Dunsmuir is a small town
in northern California,
much like Santa Mira, where
the movie takes place.
I wouldn't be surprised if Dunsmuir
was one of the inspirations
for this location
though it seems a little bit less creepy
than it's film counterpart.
Santa Mira is named after a fictional town
from an earlier Sci-Fi
horror movie and novel
called "Invasion of the Body Snatchers."
This was the start of a trend.
A lot of other properties would borrow
this fictional location for their setting,
including "AirWolf", "The Dark Tower",
and even the "Sharknado" franchise.
Challis hangs out in a bar where
he is once again, bombarded
by the overplayed
Halloween mask commercial.
He asks the bartender
to change the channel
and he puts on a football
game, which we can hear
in the background as Ellie
Grimbridge introduces herself.
Listen to the names called
out by the announcer,
- [TV announcer] ...Bernardi
finally brought him down,
not much time to do anything, but
coach Tommy Marshall has been...
- These are both
references to crew members
of the movie.
Barry Bernardi was an associate producer
and Tommy Marshall was
best boy electrician.
There are a few more crew
reference Easter eggs
that I spotted in the guest
book when Challis and Ellie
get to the hotel, including
costumer, Frances Vega Aubrey,
who signs as both Francis
Aubrey and Mr. F Vega
and property master James Rathbun.
- [Jimmy] Last episode when
we covered "Halloween II",
I mentioned how Nancy
Loomis, also known as
Nancy Kyes or Keys, I'm not exactly
sure how to say it, appears in each movie
in the original Halloween trilogy.
This time she plays none other
than Dr. Dan Challis's ex-wife, Linda.
I've seen this movie like 20 times,
and I never connected that Linda is played
by the same actress as Annie.
Mainly, because she comes
off like such a huge *****.
Another actress who appears
in each of the first three
Halloween movies is Laurie Strode herself,
Jamie Lee Curtis.
Because we of course, see her
during the television airing
of "Halloween" in this movie.
(creepy music begins)
(glass breaking)
- [Zac] I guess Dr. Challis is not a fan.
The other Jamie Lee Curtis
cameo is a bit more covert.
It is her voice that
announces the early curfew
in Santa Mira.
(haunting music begins)
- [public address announcer]
It's 6 o'clock. It's 6 o'clock.
Curfew. Curfew.
- There's one other
notable cameo appearance
and it comes from Dick Warlock.
This is the guy who played
Michael Myers in "Halloween II".
So we see him unmasked for the first time
when he appears as one of
Conal Cochran's Androids.
I know I don't normally
talk about actor cameos
and things you missed,
but it felt relevant
to bring up since this
is a spiritual successor
to the first two movies.
It's kind of like how "Shock
Treatment" is a followup
to "Rocky Horror".
Similar crew, similar cast,
similar artwork, and feel, but totally
different story.
On the drive to Santa
Mira, Challis and Ellie
read up on the town.
- [Challis] Proud community,
predominantly Irish.
- [Ellie] Irish Halloween masks?
- [Challis] In California, you never know.
- Outside of the company
producing the mask
being called Silver Shamrock,
there are a lot of references
to Ireland and Irish culture.
So let's just go over all of them
to make sure we've got our bases covered.
Dr. Challis and that weirdo he meets
both appear to be alcoholics.
Heavy drinking is a common trait
of the stereotypical Irishman.
- Drinking and doctoring,
great combination.
- Another thing Irish people are known for
can be seen in this clip.
(car exploding)
*laughter*
- [Zac] The bar he hangs
out at is decorated
with Irish murals.
For example, this one on the back wall
is a depiction of Anne Bonny,
an Irish pirate from the 1700s.
The other businesses in Santa Mira
are also themed to Irish culture.
Rafferty is a classic Irish name.
Dublin is the capital of Ireland.
The word shamrock is kind of overused.
In addition to the factory,
there's also a Shamrock Store
and a Shamrock Savings.
Though personally, I would have
gone with Leprechaun Loans.
They ended up staying at
the Rose of Shannon Motel.
A reference to the town of
Shannon in Western Ireland.
The booking office has
a huge map of Ireland
hanging on the wall.
The Kupfer family arrives
at the motel in a big RV
covered in stickers.
It's hard to make them
out, but one of them
definitely has the
colors of the Irish flag.
While touring the factory,
we learn that Silver Shamrock
used to be known for making toys,
like these windup machines.
This one depicts a group of
musically inclined insects
called the Lovebug Band,
which is a reference
to an Irish pop band from the
eighties known as Luv Bug.
The depiction of them as
insects may also be a connection
to the method by which the Halloween masks
kill the children.
They're zapped by this laser
from the Stonehenge piece,
which causes their brains to
turn into a swarm of insects
that come pouring out of their heads.
I don't care what you
think about this movie,
you gotta love that kill.
- [Jimmy] It's a great practical gag
because you see it happen in real time,
but it's not actually that
hard to throw together.
- Finally, there's the big
reveal about why Cochran
is targeting children.
I'm going to turn on the subtitles and
- Alright, roll it.
- It was the start of the
year in our old Celtic lands
and we'd be waiting in our
houses of wattles and clay.
The barriers would be down, you see,
between the real and the unreal,
and the dead might be looking in
to sit by our fires of turf.
(dramatic music rising)
Halloween...
the festival of Samhain!
- Did you catch that?
Although Cochran says it
differently than Dr. Sam Loomis
did in "Halloween II",
he tells us that children
are sacrificed during
the festival of Samhain.
Remember how Michael
defaced the chalkboard
leading Loomis to believe that his crimes
were part of a tribute?
It turns out that Cochran's
plan to eviscerate the minds
of American trick-or-treaters
comes from a similar motivation.
Which makes this the only through line
between "Halloween II"
and "Halloween III".
- There is another hint
about the true purpose
of the Silver Shamrock masks
hidden in one small detail
at the motel.
(intense scary music begins)
(creepy music begins)
- No "Halloween III"
video would be complete
without making fun of
the mature relationship
between Dr. Challis and Ellie Grimbridge.
I mean, her father just
died earlier that week
and she's already trying to
get it on with a mustached man,
literally more than twice her age.
Seriously, you're going to
investigate your father's murder,
why did you even pack that outfit?
It's so ridiculous.
- [Jimmy] Playing an older guy
who gets with younger girls
is exactly what Tom Atkins was born to do.
I mean, have you seen The Fog.
- And I'm not even making this up,
but I was looking into this movie
and learned that the scenes in Santa Mira
were filmed at a place
called Loleta, California.
- I do love a good joke
and this is the best ever.
- Despite how unintentionally funny
this movie can be at times,
and believe me, it can
be unintentionally funny.
(Silver Shamrock
commercial jingle playing)
- But despite all of that,
the way the mystery's set up
is actually really well done.
Or at least kind of well done.
There are a lot of details
that set up the fact
that the factory workers are robots,
like the explanation
of the hiring process.
- He brought in every damn
one of them factory people
from the outside.
Think he'd hire me, a local boy?
No way, turned me down flat.
- And the realization that the initial
assassin's autopsy only
contains machine parts.
- We've been doing an
autopsy on part of the car.
- It's still hilarious
when you first hear it.
There's also a little foreshadowing
about the magic element of Cochran's plan.
At the motel a woman named
Marge Guttman can be seen
reading Carlos Castaneda's
"The Eagles Gift."
From what I understand
this book is about sorcery.
Although the magic used to sacrifice
the mask wearing children is
referred to as witchcraft,
and although one of the
big Halloween three masks
is a witch, there isn't an
actual witch in the movie.
I read somewhere that Tommy Lee Wallace
named it after the Donovan
song "Season of the Witch".
Great song, but it is
also not in the movie.
The finale shows us kids
going out to trick-or-treat
all over the country, which by the way,
includes some beautiful shots
of the Halloween sunset.
Challis rescues what he thinks is Ellie,
but actually turns out to be robo Ellie.
Not sure how or why Cochran had the time
to make a perfect replica
of her just to screw
with old Challis or why
the robo Ellie never tries
to stop him until after
he's destroyed the factory.
But whatever, I'm into this.
(threatening music begins)
- [Jimmy] I got to say, I love
this movie's generous take
on how many cities actually
celebrate Halloween anymore.
I mean, I've lived in L.A. five years
and I've never once had a kid come to
my door to trick-or-treat on Halloween.
- Yeah, I was disappointed to
see the lack of decorations
on most houses when I moved out here.
After fighting her off, he
inexplicably leaves the car
behind and goes to the gas
station where the movie started
to try to get the hypnotic
advert taken off the air.
Who goes trick or
treating at a gas station?
Apparently these kids do,
and they gather around the TV
as Dr. Challis begs the
programmer to take the commercial
off of the three channels
that it's airing on.
- Wait, you never went trick
or treating at a gas station?
- Do they get out gas or candy?
- I don't remember.
- This brings us back to the main theme
that I discussed about "Halloween III".
The Silver Shamrock advert
is representative of every TV
commercial attempting to
corrupt and brainwash the youth
into becoming their ideal
consumer, regardless of any harm
that this might be
doing to them physically
or psychologically.
The bugs and snakes that pour out
of the young Kupfer boys head are symbolic
of what is going on inside
the heads of children
who were exposed to
overbearing advertising
from a young age.
The parents of these kids
do show some concern,
saying things like "don't sit too close"
or "turn down the volume", but ultimately
the kids are drawn to the
flashy colors and catchy tunes
of the broadcast.
During the factory tour, we
learned that Silver Shamrock
used to be a toy manufacturer
and eventually switched
to hypnotic masks and television programs.
In the 1980's, when
this movie takes place,
television was reaching
the peak of its popularity
and Cochran was just
following what the kids
were paying attention to.
TV shows were the new
toys and Silver Shamrock
is a stand in for any number
of malicious private companies
ready to take advantage of that.
- Like most good movie
satire, "Halloween III"
was ahead of its time.
I think it's because it's
hard to notice that stuff
when it's still happening all around you,
but then when you revisit
a movie a few years later,
all of the satirical jokes
hit you right on the head.
It's kind of funny that 40 years later,
"Stranger Things 3" covered
the exact same stuff
as Halloween 3.
- Yes and I'll definitely have
to think about covering that
on my channel sometime soon as well.
Hint.
But if the years since 1978
have taught us anything,
it's that you can't kill Michael Myers.
And even if you could, he
just won't stay dead for long.
The Halloween anthology
concept was abandoned
after the poor reception
of "Halloween III",
and in 1988, the prolific
slasher would wake up
and set his sights on a new target.
Which means we've got more
things you missed to discuss
in "Halloween 4: The
Return of Michael Myers".
Meanwhile, there is a new Halloween movie,
"Halloween Kills", just one week away.
Jimmy has been covering
everything related to Kills
lately on his channel so head
over there and drop him a sub.
Otherwise he'll be forced to
[TV Commercial] ♪ Subscribe to
Jimmy Champane! Mee Champane!
Mee Champane! Subscribe to Jimmy
Champane, on his YouTube! ♪
- [Zac] And click that video on the left
and if you love Halloween,
make sure to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week.
Ring the death bell for all notifications,
and I'll see you in the next one,
assuming we both survive.
(slow creepy version of
Silver Shamrock jangle fading)